all right thanks ted week 15 of the nfl
season
it is underway with the raiders uh close
loss last night to the chargers ron
futrell now joining us to talk
about the players and the raiders
chances to make them
okay so only three weeks left in the
nfl's regular season we'll talk about
the raiders
very slim playoff hopes in a moment but
first
let's check out the playoff chances for
the teams in the nfc
the nfc is quite a bit more wide open
as far as the super bowl odds the
packers are five to one they're the top
team in the uh nfc followed by the
saints at seven to one
then you got brady and the buccaneers
ten to one rams eleven to one and the
seahawks are fourteen to one so
you know much more competitive between
the teams in the nfc than it is the afc
not nearly as top heavy
so after the raiders lost to the
chargers on thursday in overtime
they now have only a two percent chance
of making the playoffs
they've got the dolphins on saturday a
really big game after last night's tough
loss for the raiders so they're
definitely on the outside looking in
right now miami comes to town
i imagine that game will be close to a
picket so it's going to be a must win
for the raiders
so that raiders game against the
dolphins will be here at allegiance
stadium december 26
the day after christmas now if tua plays
quarterback for the dolphins and marcus
mariota
for the raiders that'll be the first
time two hawaiian-born quarterbacks have
met
in an nfl game why not have it here on
the ninth island
at legion stadium i'm ron futrell
reporting eight sports